a coal mine close to the front line in
eastern ukraine
mines such as this one have helped fuel
industry in the donbass region and
across what was the soviet union for
over a century
but ukraine remains dependent on russia
to meet its energy needs especially coal
which is vital for fueling ukrainian
power stations
in 2014 pro-russia separatists seized
control of the majority of the mines
further depleting ukraine's access to
coal
decades of neglect means much of the
mine's infrastructure is close to
collapse
the equipment we have is from 1958 lack
of investment and government negligence
is one of the reasons why we face a
shortage and things could be difficult
this winter
another problem is that russia cut
ukraine's coal supply last month russia
has recently stopped exporting coal to
ukraine
saying that there's just too much
domestic internal demand for the natural
resource
some analysts are describing this as
nothing short of blackmail
and an effort by russia to weaponize its
vast natural resources as a means of
putting pressure on ukraine
and it's not just coal that russia is
using to try and control ukraine
these are gas pipelines similar to those
that transport russian gas across
ukraine to europe
europe relies on russia for around 35
percent of its energy needs and ukraine
gets paid transit fees which were around
2 billion dollars last year
but those days are nearly over
the nordstream 2 pipeline which is
expected to be operational next year
bypasses ukraine instead transporting
gas from russia to germany under the
baltic sea
russia is trying to split and divide
europe so for russia it's much more
better to have energy relations with
different states separately rather than
with a single big european union from
ukrainian perspective this means that
russia will have
its hands free to destabilize situation
in ukraine more actively
germany has warned russia not to use its
gas exports as a weapon but has been
criticized by other european states and
ukraine for exposing kiev to more
economic pressure from moscow
some analysts say russia's aim of trying
to keep ukraine in its sphere of
influence is impossible
it is simply not possible to have that
sort of control over your neighbors
without investing huge resources
military as well as economic because in
the end as i see it
on race issue i think moscow needs to
modify its aims
because they are simply not realistic
winter is just beginning kiev is so
worried about the potential electricity
blackouts that it's been forced to start
importing coal from as far away as the
us and colombia
some analysts say economic and energy
pressure from russia will continue
because the more ukraine talks about
future nato and eu membership
the more moscow sees red
charles drive at al jazeera toretsk
eastern ukraine